[Music]
you have how many children we have three
you have three three you I was talking
to you and I saw your husband and your
husband told me that you guys have
pretty blunt sex talk it's your case
each other first of all you're a loving
married couple um well we do we don't I
mean we speak age appropriately to our
children but if they have questions
which they often do we try to answer
frankly and to be truthful I listen to
Howard Stern in the morning I listen so
they have a lot of questions actually
wait you listen to Howard Stern why your
kids are in there I do actually yes I do
because you know what I just got so
tired of pretending that I was listening
to NPR all the time so I just now
right sure because you hear the Howard
show twice and the replays my kids hear
a little of the unsavory stuff and
they're horrified by it there's totally
scandalized by it so it's fine and then
they asked me questions and then but you
think that's actually good and there's a
lot of people actually believe that it's
good for kids to obviously hear some
they truths so much that I haven't told
them just from going to school just from
going to public school in New York City
so there are seasoned professionals
there's nothing I can really teach them
that they don't already know I'm saying
they know a lot more about sex than I do
then I'd your grandmother is this true
that your grandmother gave the women in
your family very blunt advice when I
came to sex oh my gosh she did she
informed us that you should never give
[ __ ] so I was I was raised by my
grandmother she really did
consider and I'm not could she knit that
on a sampler embroidery what did that
come from but he was very Catholic and
it really did consider that a [ __ ]
was like the depth of depravity and that
only like women who roamed the earth and
negligees would do it he would have been
just like women at negligees in the
middle of the day right rooster with
like a big ash yeah that was that was
there okay how did she bring this up I
know I was gonna say you're sitting
around and what if she's making a peach
cobbler and then she just turned to you
and said yeah yes yeah correct we've got
three children we're doing something
right dirtier things that you can do
there are things she didn't even
consider that she should have warned me
about yeah grandma was not doing her job
she could have talked about yeah there's
a grandma here at the show tonight who's
probably not like a nanny Aloha
[Applause]
that woman is a dirty birdie yeah
you